brick mansions is directed by the editor
of transporter three Columbiana and
taken to brick mansions stars Paul
Walker David Bell and RZA and what this
movies about is an undercover cop and an
ex-con who team up to infiltrate this
area of Detroit that's incredibly
crime-filled known as brick mansions
because RZA has a rocket that he is
going to launch and just blow up
everything the one guy's extremely good
at parkour he's jumping all around like
the guy in the beginning of Casino
Royale member that scene that was so
awesome
Paul Walker is an undercover cop who's
extremely good at not being shot by a
whole bunch of bullets so they team up
to get this done and I was really hoping
this would be a good movie because
despite the fact that the public's view
of Paul Walker as an actor isn't
extremely high I really did like that
man and I feel terrible about what
happened to him and I was really hoping
this would be a very good epitaph to him
even when he unfortunately passed away
he was leaving a charity event I mean
that guy tried to do so many great
things and everything I ever heard about
him was awesome unfortunately this movie
is not awesome brick mansions is a film
that as I said in my intro is directed
by somebody who makes action look like
this is a remake of the original film
called district 13 that was directed by
the man who went on to helm the very
first taken film it actually has the
same actor in it David Bell who does all
the stunts himself and he's so good at
it he's very convincing with the stunt
work except the way this film is
actually filmed and the way it's cut
together is so frenetic that you can't
actually tell what's happening sometimes
it just seems like this really fast body
blurs by and kicks somebody in the face
and the sad thing is is I know these
guys are doing incredible stunts and if
they would just film it in a way that
was equally incredible this movie could
have been a fun stupid action movie
instead it is a stupid stupid
unintentional comedy halfway through
this movie my friend I just looked at
each other and we were like oh man
and RZA is not intimidating in any way
as the villain he's actually kind of
laughable in this movie the majority of
his dialogue is very poorly delivered
and most of the people in this movie
actually have a hard time with English
language the main guide David Bell you
can tell that almost all of his lines if
not all of them are audio dubbed because
they rarely ever show more than a second
or two of him actually speaking close up
because you can just tell like
everything he says is audio dub because
his English probably wasn't perfected
and it's funny because there's a line in
the trailer where Paul Walker looks at
him and says who taught you how to speak
English that line was not in the movie
and I have a feeling that originally
they were just going to use his actual
voice and Paul Walker was gonna make
that joke and they're like you know what
let's just Audio dub all of his lines to
sound like perfect English and we'll cut
that joke out of the movie because
that's what they did but the central
story of this film is so so cheesy with
this rocket being launched and they have
to stop it and like everyone has
incredible technology like they hold up
an iPad and they're like look at this
satellite imagery
and it's like just zooms in perfectly
with like this computerized look it's
like that fake movie technology that no
one would ever have on their iPad this
moment in this movie where Paul Walker
and David Bell get captured and the guy
who captures them looks at the guard and
says these people are worth more than
your life whatever you do they must not
die two seconds later when they escape
everyone just starts shooting at them
I'm like it doesn't make sense and then
all of a sudden Paul Walker's character
is able to do all these backflips and
side flips where it's like wait a second
he's not the parkour guy like they make
it very clear in the movie that Paul
Walker is in awe at this guy's parkour
capabilities and all of a sudden Paul
Walker is like doing side flips and
doing backflips and everything and it's
like wow you are a very good undercover
cop
unfortunately this movie is actually
laughably bad the story is stupid the
technology is like non-existent on earth
and if it is existent it's like in NASA
not on somebody's iPad the action is
filmed and edited extremely
unconvincingly with terrible choppy cut
quick cuts shots when you have actors
who are doing awesome stunts but you're
not filming it in a way that show
cases that you're just making this
mind-numbingly violent movie that will
just kind of make audience members laugh
when you have a woman who's dressed like
a stripper another woman swinging a
chain and all that slow motion like an
Legend of Hercules where it's like slow
more like oh that's the kind of slow
motion fast motion stuff that is all
throughout this movie this guy has no
style of his own it just seems like a
copy off of current day action trends
that suck I'm gonna give brick mansions
a D let me know what you guys think if
you do see this movie or what you
thought of the original or its sequel as
always guys thanks so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]